an irreplaceable american treasure is
under attack a treasure that existed
long before america was founded
petroglyphs are ancient writings carved
into stone and left by ancient
civilizations they tell the stories of
people who survived here thousands of
years before european settlers arrived
but their own survival is now being
threatened chris van cleave explains
and you can see there's
an anthro here steve acerson walks the
west searching for rock art ancient
stone etchings known as petroglyphs
depicting man's early history in north
america and they are increasingly
endangered by modern man we
have multiple
rock art boulders up on this hillside
that have been damaged from bullets
impacts and the images are actually
being lost on these boulders
here in utah carvings made four thousand
years ago by the now extinct fremont
tribe fell victim to target practice we
probably had five or six that are
totally
gone now if we can't connect to the land
and what it's telling us we are a lost
people eileen quintana a member of the
navajo nation works with acerson so this
whole hillside has been
exposed to the gunfire acerson reported
the damage to the bureau of land
management and his group the utah rock
art association
positioned boulders to shield the
petroglyphs that way when they shoot up
here the bullets will hit
the clay or the dummy rock and protect
the rock hard image here's an owl or
quail figure here but his small group
can't be everywhere 150 miles away in
moab utah profanity defaced a carving
celebrating the birth of a child 3000
years ago nearby a rock climber inserted
bolts into another petroglyph the
climber claims he mistook a
thousand-year-old carving for modern day
graffiti someone is outright vandalism
some of it is profiteering
but some of it is just stupidity and
ignorance arizona congressman raul
grialva wants to increase penalties for
anyone damaging a petroglyph what can
congress do congress can begin with
resources to strengthen the preservation
arm that looks at history and looks at
cultural resources and sacred sites but
there's not even a reliable count of the
number of petroglyphs in this country
and most that have been found are in
desolate areas making them hard to
police we do have some problem areas
where once you know one person carves
their name
someone will come by and see that and
they think that that's an acceptable
practice angela richmond is a ranger in
arches national park we see areas where
you just get a bunch of names kind of
piled on top of each other and
unfortunately some of those are over you
know prehistoric
rock art or markings you things that are
you know over a thousand years old but
criminal charges for their destruction
are rare of six documented incidents
this year one resulted in charges that
were filed and efforts in congress to
better protect petroglyphs have failed
in three recent attempts
why do you think there's been
an issue in getting some of this
through congress getting lands protected
if we were talking about dinosaur
fossils you'd probably have an easier
time protecting the land there's profit
involved there's extraction whether it
is gas
natural gas oil in some areas mining and
others and there is a very powerful
profit motive that drives those
decisions the lichen and
as steve acerson continues his search
for new rock art he knows what it will
take to protect the legacy of people's
long gone so it's going to have to be a
cultural shift to where people realize
that stuff needs to be protected and
saved because when it's lost it's just
like tearing a page out of a history
book
and potentially wiping away the last
traces of those who came before us for
cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleave in washington
they're beautiful but you've got to
wonder like what compels someone to go
vandalize right well i like the he said
ignorance and i think with a story like
this now you know so it's like what do
you do with that information right
education will develop that appreciation
one would hope to try and preserve these
sites because frankly it could see how
some folks might happen upon that and
not not think about it and not even
think about what they're doing if you
want to write your name i'll go to a
sketch pad or something you don't have
to do it at arches national park there's
that right
absolutely well maybe more people will
know now and have a better appreciation